this climate summit is ultimately about
one thing cutting greenhouse gases by
enough to keep global warming to one and
a half degrees an uphill battle because
emissions are still rising the global
economy chucks out 60 gigatonnes that's
60 billion tons of carbon emissions a
year that's a combination of carbon
dioxide methane and other greenhouse
gases
the bulk of these come of course from
the world's biggest and dirtiest
economies based on the latest data china
leads the polluter pack with around 12
gigatons followed by the us at around
half that
eu and coal dependent india emit about
the same
and fossil fuel exporting russia behind
them
the uk is just one percent of global
emissions half a gigatonne of greenhouse
gases but our banks businesses and
imports account for much more and you
don't have to be the biggest polluter in
the world to have big responsibilities
at cop
forested nations like brazil store vast
amounts of carbon but only if they don't
cut down their trees
the great news is heading into the
summit
134 countries have promised to cut
emissions to zero in the coming decades
in shades of green
are all those that have put their plans
into law or are saying they will but in
yellow those with no net zero plan at
all
quite a lot of green so where does that
get us
sadly not that far here in the uk we're
aiming for net zero by 2050 and a 68 cut
by 2030 the us promises to halve its
emissions by 2030 both pretty much in
line with where we need to go but china
the biggest player remember is pledging
only to peak its emissions in 2030
getting to zero in 2060. and australia
pledging net zero by 2050 but only
committed to a 28 cut in the near term
but it's the near term that's important
because on current trends we could be
getting close to one and a half degrees
as soon as twenty thirty
so let's go back to the global emissions
picture to have a good chance of
reaching two degrees of warming annual
emissions must fall by around 13
gigatonnes by 2030.
to put us on a safe trajectory to one
and a half degrees it's estimated we
need to halve emissions by 2030
and one and a half degrees matters
because it's a tipping point beyond
which sea level rise accelerates weather
extremes like cyclones heat and rainfall
become more frequent and intense
the scale of the challenge for cop 26 is
almost unimaginable
but the consequences of not taking it on
more unimaginable still